on afterwards former President Jimmy
Carter he's interviewed by NBC News
anchor Brian Williams HW brands writes
about our nation's seventh president in
the new biography Andrew Jackson his
life and times this talk from the
Southern Festival of Books in Nashville
Tennessee is an hour welcome to this
session I'm an top Levitch I'm executive
director of the Tennessee Historical
Society and it's my pleasure this
afternoon to welcome you to this session
of the southern festival of books
we're also very delighted that this is a
session that's being taped by c-span to
for their book festivals sessions and
I'll have an instruction related to that
to say to you in a moment as you all
know the southern festival books is a
pretty major undertaking by volunteers
and requires a lot of resources so after
this session if you see the fellows in
the hall with their tip jars and you
feel so moved we encourage you to please
make a donation or if you like you can
become a friend of the southern festival
which is also a marvelous thing the way
we're going to structure the session
this afternoon is after our speaker
makes his remarks we'll hold questions
until that point until the end of his
presentation because we are taping this
we ask you to please use the microphone
that is to your left and the easiest way
to handle that is if you'll walk around
the rear of the room and line up at the
microphone that facilitates questions
quite a quite a bit I know some of you
were here in the previous session and
and saw how that works now I'll
introduce our speaker HW brands
originally from Oregon bill has a PhD in
history from the University of Texas at
Austin and I imagine he's feeling pretty
good today after Texas trounced Oklahoma
last night so at least one team in
orange one yesterday
one of those you teens and Veloz has a
connection to Tennessee he was once
visiting professor of history at
Vanderbilt which he know has a fine
reputation for its history department he
was at Texas A&M for 17 years and then
for some reason Austin welcomed him back
even though he was an Aggie I guess at
that time at least an adopted one and
he's now the Anderson Centennial
professor of history at the University
of Texas bill is the acclaimed author of
more than 19 books and of many articles
and reviews and I would encourage you if
you want to find out more about his work
to go to the website HW brands dot-com
where you'll find an extensive list of
those works among biographies he has
done Teddy Roosevelt Benjamin Franklin
and also Woodrow Wilson which is a
pretty wide-ranging group of folks to
cover his newest book is on Andrew
Jackson a life and times and I have had
the pleasure of reading the book and
it's the first biography of Jackson
that's appeared really in more than
twenty years
so with those very brief remarks and
introduction I'm going to turn things
over to Professor brands
thank you and for those very nice
remarks and thank you to the southern
festival for having me here I think
these book festivals are a great event
for authors I think they're very good
for readers and forgetting the two of us
together I'm gonna talk a little bit
today about why I wrote a book on Andrew
Jackson and in part I'm doing this
because I've fallen out of the habit of
writing practices two books a preface is
where an author usually explains why he
or she wrote the book at hand but as a
reader I often found that preface --is
got in the way of getting on with the
story so I decided to dispense with prep
with a preface and hopes that the reader
would dive in on page one and the story
would carry the reader forward as Ann
said there hasn't been a full biography
of Andrew Jackson in over 20 years and
the one that everybody refers to when
they talk about in the 20 years was
Robert Remedies three volumes on Andrew
Jackson they're a wonderful work of
historical nonfiction of biography but I
decided that there ought to be a Jackson
between the covers of one book and so I
decided but there's I after I made this
decision I discovered that in fact I
couldn't find a full one volume
biography of Andrew Jackson it seems
that when biographers take on Jackson
they get so enthralled by the subject
that they go on for two volumes like
Marcus James or three volumes right like
Robert Remini or James Parton so the the
Jack's and biographies tend to be these
these very large things and I decided
that I wanted to do it in one volume so
that was part of the reason that I took
on this assignment that I assigned
myself this biography of Jackson another
reason had to do with the fact well it
was about the election it was during the
election of 2000 and I recall sitting
and watching the presidential debates of
that year when Al Gore
was debating george w bush and i
reflected on the fact i thought it was
very curious that here were two men who
between them had three Ivy League
degrees but in the debates if you
remember they each competed most
vigorously with the other to come across
as the one who had the real common touch
they were running away from their elite
family backgrounds their elite education
and trying to make them each was trying
to make himself appear just the common
man and I wondered about this I wonder
where did this come from because it's
peculiar in American politics that
presidents have to have a common touch
more so than other candidates for
example if you are a senator from a
state it's no complaint against you be
called the distinguished senator from
Tennessee or the distinguished senator
from Massachusetts or taxes but
presidents are never called the
distinguished president in fact if you
call the president distinguished the
president would probably pull out his
spokesman to try to deny the charge
because presidents are supposed to be
just ordinary folks now I knew enough
about American history to know that this
wasn't always so George Washington would
not have been in the slightest insulted
or put off to have been called
distinguished in fact he probably would
have wanted some adjectives more exalted
than that but it was only in the 19th
century that this idea that the
president ought to be just an ordinary
person just like the rest of us took
hold and I'll confess that I knew enough
about American history to know that it
all started with Andrew Jackson but I
wanted to investigate this further so I
thought that Jackson would be a good
subject to try to understand how we
arrived at the situation we are in today
where the presidency the president is
peculiarly the representative of all the
people of the United States and if you
think about it for a minute the
president is the only political officer
in the United States
that everybody potentially gets to vote
for now when I say everybody there are
some obvious exceptions to that and
furthermore still we don't exactly vote
for the presidential candidates
technically we vote for electors but
that's a huge step forward from what it
was forward a huge step in some
direction from what it was before Andrew
Jackson became president
because until Jackson until Jackson ran
for president in the 1820s ordinary
people didn't even get to vote for
electors in fact the presidential
electors were chosen for the most part
by state legislatures now if you really
know your constitutional history or if
you were really paying close attention
during the 2000 election campaign when
things got hung up in Florida you may
remember that you have no constitutional
right to vote for president in fact I
mean even for the electors for president
there's nothing in the Constitution that
says that ordinary people get to choose
the electors all it says is that the
states shall choose electors and the
reason this came up in the 2000 election
was when the recount was disputed in
Florida there was some talk of the
Florida Legislature deciding who would
get the Florida electors and so if you
go back and look at your Constitution
it's just it's a matter of habit
in many cases state law but it's not a
matter of the Constitution but anyway
ever since Andrew Jackson's era this
notion that the people get to vote for
president even if somewhat indirectly
through the electors which mean they
become a relatively straightforward pass
through it's only since Jackson's age
that that has taken hold and in fact
when Jackson was inaugurated in 1829
there was this understanding that
Jackson was peculiarly the people's
president and in a way that the no
president before him had been and in
fact in a way that every president after
Jackson would strive for and it got to
be fairly ridiculous
actually when william henry harrison was
running for president in 1840 william
henry harrison was a college man at a
time when people who had gone to college
constituted maybe 5% of the population
he was wealthy he was well-heeled but he
ran what was called then and has been
known by historians ever since the log
cabin and and hard cider campaign he was
trying to essentially out Jackson
Jackson and Andrew Jackson thought that
it was a scandal of course the fact that
Harrison was evade the Whig political
party in Jackson didn't like his
politics contributed to Jackson's view
of the whole thing but nonetheless this
idea that the president should be the
represent of just ordinary people took
hold with a vengeance and has never let
go so these were among the reasons that
I chose that I decided to write a book a
ban Andrew Jackson and there's there's
one more that I'll share with you and
this is this is more personal and it
there's no this isn't really a good
reason but it's it's one of the main
reasons about probably 10 years ago
maybe more than 12 or 13 years ago in my
ambition as a young historian I decided
that I was going to become the Will
Durant of American history now those of
you who are a little bit older may know
about will and Arielle Durant's story of
civilization it was all the history
that's fit to print in something like 14
volumes or 20 volumes or something like
that it was a multi multi volume history
of humanity and it was a huge bestseller
when it came out it's often been thought
to be sort of a popularized version of
history but heaven for heaven's sakes I
mean how can you do any better than that
if you're gonna take on all of human
history well anyway I decided that
somebody ought to do that for American
history because nobody had and naturally
I thought it ought to be me
so I proposed this idea to a publisher
and I said here's what I want to do I
want to write a history of the American
people and do it in about I don't know
six or seven volumes
and this publisher took one look at me
and sort of yawn and said I you know
these multi-volume histories they just
don't go anywhere so I don't think so
well I was somewhat put off by this
rejection but not entirely I still
thought it was worth doing but I
realized that if I was going to do it I
would have to do it covertly I would
have to do it by stealth and so what I
got in mind was my secret multiple
volume history of the United States but
it wasn't gonna be called that in fact
it would sort of sneak up on people but
it was going to take the form of a
series of biographies now from the very
beginning from the time I first started
writing history which is now about 20
years ago I was peculiarly attracted to
the genre of by well yeah sort of the
genre of biography as in a book about a
life but even in even in the the books
that I write that aren't formally
biographies they tend to hang on
individual characters now this is partly
because in my own experience of reading
history and in my experience of watching
other people read history and talk about
history and in my experience teaching
it's a lot easier to get the story of
history across when you attach it to
individuals you can write about the
history of ideas and you can write about
social classes and you can write about
economic developments and they're really
hard for ordinary people people who
don't have a pre-existing interest in
history to get a grip on but once you
start telling the stories of individuals
then people respond to individuals
because to some extent we all go and
read history because why we want to know
what other people's lives were like so I
decided that I was going to do this
series of biographies now I had to
choose my figures carefully because they
had to be because
this was gonna be not simply a bunch of
lives but it was gonna be a history of
the American people told through these
lives so it's no coincidence as Anne
pointed out that the subtitle of my book
the title is Andrew Jackson the subtitle
is his life and times I come at
biography from the direction of history
I'm a historian so I want to know how
the life fits in with the times and for
me illuminating the times is as
important as telling the life story
people who write biographies tend to
come from one of two directions the one
direction is the historian like me who
usually places the life fairly firmly in
the times and then there are those who
come to biography from the direction of
journalism and so they're working from
the present to the past they're often
less interested in the times and more
interested in just sort of filling up
the story with the life and both
approaches are perfectly valid but it's
if you're interested in knowing what to
expect out of a particular biography it
would pay you to take ten seconds to
read the dust jacket and find out a
little bit about the author and if you
if you like the full life with
relatively little of the times
obstructing the view then choose a
biography by someone whose background is
as a journalist and probably the best
practitioner of this version is David
McCullough who started out as a
journalist and has been writing well
nonfiction
history and biography nice biographies
of john adams and harry truman are
wonderful and i you know they both won
the pulitzer prize so he can't complain
about that i wish i could have that kind
of complaint anyway but those of us who
come at it from history tend to think
more in terms of how does the life
illuminate the times so my first venture
in this field was a biography of
Theodore Roosevelt Theodore Roosevelt
while I choked wife chose Theodore
Roosevelt for a couple of reasons partly
because he was this big larger-than-life
character partly because and this is
this is something that I'm I'm trying to
decide whether applies to Andrew Jackson
or not Theodore Roosevelt is far enough
in the past that the politics of his
life are no longer controversial
Theodore Roosevelt was extremely
controversial when he was alive he was
beloved by certain Republicans he was a
Republican he was beloved by certain
Republicans and some Democrats but he
was despised by most Republicans even
though he was a Republican and by a lot
of Democrats and it was for taking
controversial stands on issues of the
day but the issues of Theodore
Roosevelt's day are not the issues by
and large of our day and so
conservatives and liberals for different
and actually sometimes contradictory
reasons can embrace Theodore Roosevelt
so somebody writing about Theodore
Roosevelt doesn't have to worry about
stepping on the toes of any particular
group I wrote so and I chose so Theodore
Roosevelt was my first entry in this I
haven't figured out how many volumes
this is gonna be actually but it'll
probably be about six or seven maybe
eight but he was the first entry into
this and he was chosen partly for his
personal character its characteristics
but also be because he nicely covers the
period from the Civil War up to and
through the First World War this is the
period of the industrialization of the
American economy
the modernization of American society
the emergence of the full-blown modern
political system and also the emergence
of sort of modern questions of where
does where does government fit in the
life of society Theodore Roosevelt was
the first progressive president anyway
that's why I chose Rosen vol.2 was I
backed up now this is just volume two in
the order they were written item
Theodore Roosevelt will probably be
about volume I don't know four
or so volume 1 volume 1 the second one
written chronologically was a biography
a date of Benjamin Franklin now by the
time I got to Benjamin Franklin it was I
was really clear on what I was trying to
accomplish and this was going to fit in
this this series Benjamin Franklin was
perfect for me because he covers the
basically the 18th century in American
history's born in the first decade of
the 18th century he dies in the last
decade of the 18th century and in his
case if the if the chore of what shall I
say the chore of American society the
task of American society during Theodore
Roosevelt's life was coming to grips
with modernization the task of American
society in Benjamin Franklin's life was
developing an American identity and in
fact that's the reason I called the book
the first American and I used the phrase
in a variety of meanings in the first
place he was the first and in terms of
foremost he was the most famous the most
distinguished American of his generation
but he was also well he was also the
first as I see it of the revolutionary
generation to perceive an identity of
Americans separate from their identity
as Englishmen and so Franklin saw the
need for independence before just about
anybody else did but lastly Franklin it
really established you could say the
archetype for the American character and
very much about very much of what people
think when they think about an American
character you can find in Benjamin
Franklin anyway so that's why I chose
Franklin now the third volume in this
series and this is going to be
chronologically volume 2 is Andrew
Jackson conveniently for me no it's not
convenient I didn't choose him by
accident but conveniently for my design
Andrew Jackson was born in 1767 so his
life overlaps a little bit with Benjamin
Franklin's but that but that is good
because when somebody is a child they're
not involved in the public affairs of
the day how
as little more than a child Andrew
Jackson was involved with the biggest
public event of certainly the first
quarter century of his life the American
Revolution now I can't prove this and so
I hesitate to say it was much conviction
but Andrew Jackson had to have been one
of the youngest one of the youngest
soldiers in the American Revolution he
rode as a courier in the Carolinas at
the age of 13 now that that's about as
young as you can get and still be
allowed anywhere near soldiers but it
also meant that he was at the war's end
he was one of the youngest veterans of
the war which also meant that because he
lived to a relatively ripe old age he
lived on into the middle of the 19th
century so Jackson's years are 1767 to
1845 which means that for somebody like
me who's trying to write this history of
the United States he covers this long
period and he allows me to develop all
sorts of important themes in American
history during that period in particular
what happens to the revolution with
Franklin I can fight the revolution and
the Americans win their independence and
they consolidate their grip over the
eastern half of what's now the United
States and in Franklin's last few years
unsatisfied with the way things are
going under the Articles of
Confederation they decide to write a new
constitution and fortunately for my
purposes Franklin presided over well he
was the ex-officio host for the
Constitutional Convention in his
hometown of Philadelphia and he weighed
in at particular critical moments and he
gave the constitution his blessing and
he provided me with the great with my
growl all calls a great closing line I
stole it so it's not mine but I end the
book by saying that when Franklin and
the other drafters of the Constitution
came out of
mentioned in September 1787 and I'll
remind you because I reminded the reader
that the Constitutional Convention was
held in secret nobody who wasn't a
member of the convention got to listen
in and in fact the secret was the secret
kept for about thirty years it was only
much later when James Madison publishes
notes that we could figure out who said
what at the convention but anyway
Franklin walks out of Independence Hall
the Statehouse in Philadelphia at the
end of the Constitutional Convention and
a woman of Philadelphia is walking along
the street and everybody for the last
three months has been very curious about
what's going on inside and so this woman
asked Franklin says dr. Franklin what
have you given us by your three months
labor and he says madam a republic if
you can keep it well that's my jumping
off point for the Andrew Jackson book
the question is could we keep it and
that's that's the fundamental task I
said there was a task for American
society during the Roosevelt years and
during the Franklin years well the task
for American society during the Jackson
years is could we keep the Republic and
I will say that during the early going
the answer to that question was hardly
foreordained because and I hope I don't
offend or disappoint anybody in here
when I say that I am NOT one of these
people even though I write even though I
wrote no no even though because I wrote
a book about Benjamin Franklin one of
the founders I'm not one of these people
who thinks that the founders were this
generation of demigods geniuses who were
far better than we are who were greater
in virtue greater and intelligence who
did this wonderful thing and all we can
do is hold it up there in awe no in fact
I know perfectly well because I know
what Benjamin Franklin and his
contemporaries thought of their own
handiwork
and it was confirmed by what I learned
while I was researching Andrew Jackson
the drafters of the Constitution knew
perfectly well that there were two
serious flaws in their work and these
were so serious that everybody at the
time and everybody for the next 70 years
held their breath wondering if this
Constitution that they had created
weren't simply going to implode and the
two fundamental flaws in the
Constitution were number one the
question of sovereignty which part of
the government is actually supreme is it
the national government or is it the
States
you cannot tell from reading the
Constitution now the reason you can't
tell is the drafters of the Constitution
do liberabit Lee fudged it I've asked a
question of constitutional scholars that
I know legal theorists and I asked them
if anybody were going to write a
constitution for a state for a country
suppose you've got this country and it's
an absolutely blank slate regarding its
politics what it ever occur to anyone to
set up a federal system and the Uniform
answer is no nobody ever would
the only reason federal systems get set
up is that they get superimposed on some
pre-existing political or sometimes
ethnic division in society in the case
of the United States there were these 13
pre-existing States and they didn't want
they weren't about to vote themselves
out of existence anyway so this question
of call it nationalism versus states
rights that was a fundamental question a
fundamental flaw in the Constitution
because the founding charter of this new
organization ought to say when push
comes
- of who gets the last word well that
was bad enough but the second
fundamental flaw with the Constitution
and the one that made the first one
about this question of sovereignty so
explosive was the issue of slavery
because everybody could tell from 1787
that there was a basic contradiction in
American politics between the claimed in
the Declaration of Independence which of
course is not part of the Constitution
but nonetheless establishes what
Americans believed about their form of
government the basic claim in the
Declaration of Independence that all men
are created equal and the existence of
slavery which demonstrated quite clearly
that however men might have been created
on this world or at least in this
country they definitely were not equal
so it's the task of as it turns out
Jackson's generation to deal with these
questions what are you gonna do about it
and it turns out that Jackson's
generation starting even before Jackson
himself comes to political maturity
starts to deal with these questions in
as early as 1798 when the Federalists
dominated Congress passed the Alien and
Sedition Acts the opposition Republicans
now these are the forerunners of the
modern Democrats Jett Thomas Jefferson's
party filed petitions claiming that
these laws were not valid these were the
so-called Kentucky and Virginia
resolutions which proclaimed the
doctrine of nullification nullification
is the belief that states can refuse to
enforce can forbid the enforcement of
federal laws that the particular states
find obnoxious if the state of Tennessee
doesn't like the latest income tax
federal income tax in the state of
Tennessee would simply refuse to collect
it and prevent federal agents from
collecting it this was the essence of
nullification it arose in 1798 and it
was supported by no less figures than
James Madison and Thomas Jefferson it
would arise again with a vengeance in
Andrew Jackson's presidency because the
state of South Carolina Jackson's native
state would proclaim the light the right
to nullify said if Tennessee didn't want
to enforce a federal tax well that's
what South Carolina didn't want to do
and the Union nearly broke apart during
Jackson's presidency this was the first
well you could call close brush with
secession now in fact by the time
Jackson was president Jackson had
sufficient political prestige he had
sufficient prestige as a military leader
that he could stare down the south
carolinians Jackson when he heard that
South Carolina was threatening to secede
ordered his Secretary of War to lay
plans for the creation for the
enlistment of an army of 200,000 men
which Jackson intended personally to
lead to South Carolina when a South
Carolina congressman was preparing at
the end of the legislative session the
federal session was preparing to go to
South Carolina he stopped in at the
White House and asked President Jackson
if he had a message for his constituents
in South Carolina and Jackson said yes I
do tell your friends in South Carolina
that if any of them should breathe a
word of secession which was the logical
consequence of nullification if any of
them should breathe a word of secession
I will hang them from the highest tree I
can find
Jackson at the time was the most popular
man in America Jackson was the great
military hero of his generation
when Jackson threatened to March an army
into South Carolina people took him
seriously and South Carolina shortly
backed down now fast forward 30 years by
the way when this particular crisis
ended it was a crisis over a federal tax
it was a crisis over a tariff what the
South Carolinians called the tariff of
abominations needless to say the
Congress that passed it didn't call it
the tariff of abominations any more than
Parliament from your study of American
history you will recall the so called
Intolerable Acts
well when Parliament passed these
measures they weren't labeled the
intolerable accident that was something
that the Americans put on but anyway
when South Carolina backed down and
Jackson could claim satisfaction for
holding the Union together he predicted
that the problem hadn't been solved
because the constitutional question the
nation or the states that remained
subject to debate Jackson at that time
predicted that the issue would rise
again but he said the next time it arose
it wouldn't be over a tariff it would be
over slavery because the second theme
that runs through Jackson's life this
question of the struggle between the
nation and the states the second theme
is evolving attitudes toward and
practice of slavery this book I wrote
about Andrew Jackson is in part a tale
of an analysis of how American views of
slavery changed over time and it's quite
remarkable in 1787 when the drafters
went to Philadelphia and when they
decided not to decide
what to do about slavery they took a
halfway position they said 20 years from
now no more slave trade okay no more
importing of slaves into the United
States by 1787 the northern states were
beginning to abolish slavery and it
looked as though slavery was a dying
institution in part because of the
Republican conscience that with smaller
Republican conscious that was developing
in the country and as Americans began to
realize that you know slavery and this
idea that people ought to be able to
govern their own affairs that's a basis
for republicanism they don't go together
so that was part of it part of it too
was the evolution of the American
economy so that slavery had been
marginally profitable in the North in
the 18th century but by the 1780s it had
become unprofitable
and most of the founders thought that it
would probably continue to lose
profitability and as this Republican
conscience grew more acute and as the
profitability of slavery diminished then
eventually slavery would be abolished
state-by-state and that's important by
the way it was going to be
state-by-state
no one not Andrew Jackson not Thomas
Jefferson not George Washington not even
Abraham Lincoln believe it or not
thought that the federal government had
the right to emancipate slaves at least
not without a constitutional amendment
and that's why Lincoln even when he
issued the Emancipation Proclamation in
1863 at the same time said there's got
to be an amendment to the Constitution
because you can read that original
Constitution there's nothing in there
that says that the president can
emancipate slaves there's nothing in
there that even hints that Congress can
emancipate slaves so as long as the
cause until the Constitution spoke on
slavery then slavery was going to be
this ongoing problem anyway Jackson is
part of the
emerging attitude toward slavery now I'm
gonna tell you some of the challenges
that confront a person writing a life
about Andrew Jackson in contrast for
example to somebody writing about
Theodore Roosevelt when I wrote my book
about Theodore Rose Oh while I was
writing after the book came out I had
all sorts of people come up to me and
say you know Theodore Roosevelt he's
always been my favorite president and
their reasons for that makes sense when
I was writing about Benjamin Franklin I
had a lot of people come up to me and
say Benjamin Franklin
he was always been my favorite founding
father when I told people I was working
on Andrew Jackson now I don't live in
Tennessee I live in Texas and when I was
writing about Andrew Jackson I don't
think I had anybody come up to me and
say Andrew Jackson is my favorite
president and I won't say this put me
off at all no in fact it caused me to
realize that this is me the author
speaking that this book potentially
could be all the more important for
precisely that reason and here's why I
knew that Andrew Jackson was the most
popular political figure of in America
in the first the whole first half of the
19th century Andrew Jackson was the
great hero of his generation in fact
after the Battle of New Orleans in 1815
and for the rest of his life Andrew
Jackson was often referred to simply as
the hero and if you just spoke those
words it was sort of like you know in
the the field of American pop music you
speak about the king well I've been as
you're talking about Elvis Presley if
you're talking about in American
politics you spoke about the hero it was
Andrew Jackson if you look in the index
to an atlas to the United States and you
look down you find the most commonplace
names
County cities towns and so forth lakes
and everything named for individuals
there are two names that predominate you
know what two names those are Jackson is
one and Franklin is the other yes so I
got at least those two bases covered now
but there's but why is this so and in
fact there are any number of people who
are named boys mostly who are named
Andrew Jackson and Jones Andrew Jackson
Murphy Andrew Jackson this in fact there
is a fellow that I know in Texas
he's a 92 years old he's a retired chief
justice of the Texas Supreme Court and
he always went by the name his last name
is Polk he always went by the name Jack
Pope but it turns out as he told me
because I've got to know him he's
actually Andrew Jackson Pope and he was
old enough and he I can I don't I don't
know if he was born in Tennessee or not
he might have been one that I recently
got a lot couple years ago I wrote a
book on the early history of Texas and
the Texas Revolution one of the things I
discovered there you may all know this
but I didn't know this that there seems
to there has been from the early 19th
century almost a pipeline from Tennessee
to Texas it seems that everybody who got
to Texas came from Tennessee sometimes
for good reasons sometimes for bad
reasons sometimes for almost well I
don't know if these two words go
together ludicrously tragic reasons I is
I'm well is the story of Sam Houston
well-known in Tennessee I mean it
certainly is in Texas but it's but the
Tennessee origins of Sam Houston's Texas
career are not all that well-known Sam
Houston is one of the most remarkable
figures in American history his is
really a case of you couldn't make this
stuff up because nobody would believe it
but anyway and of course Sam Houston was
a protege of Andrew Jackson okay so
here's the juxtaposition I've got here's
the question that I have to answer as
this biographer Andrew Jackson as as a
historian how is it that Andrew Jackson
was this great figure in the 19th
century there was nobody bigger in fact
I can't think of an individual the
entire 19th century who rivaled Andrew
Jackson in popularity in perceived
importance conceivably for northerners
Abraham Lincoln after the by the end of
the Civil War needless to say not for
all southerners but Andrew Jackson was
this he really stood way above everybody
else but now as I said he's nobody
outside of Tennessee's favorite
president and in fact and why is that
well
here's I think the essential reason and
that is that Andrew Jackson was the
quintessential man of his time and his
time was not is not our time why is it
that people can warm up to Benjamin
Franklin so easily well frankly because
Benjamin Franklin is I think of the
founding fathers the most modern I could
very easily imagine Benjamin Franklin
being lifted out of the 18th century
give him a change of clothes and put him
on the street of Philadelphia today well
in fact if you've ever been to
Philadelphia in the last several years
you know he's there there are two guys
who make their living just impersonating
Benjamin Franklin and if you're going to
have a convention or a meeting or
something in Philadelphia you want to
hire one of these guys in fact I gave a
lecture in Philadelphia and after my
book on Franklin came out and they
didn't tell me who was gonna introduce
me and it turned out that Benjamin
Franklin himself introduced me and he
said it was a pretty good biography of
him he said I got a few things wrong but
for the most part he liked it anyway so
Benjamin Franklin is quite modern
Theodore Roosevelt is modern in his use
of things like the media theater roseola
Sencha Lee pioneered created the modern
presidency as this institution under the
24-hour glare of the media but Andrew
Jackson Andrew Jackson is very much a
man of his time and his times were not
our times and so there are two things
that people know about Andrew Jackson
one this is the first question this is
there are people who will come up to me
when I'm at a book signing or something
with hostility on their face because
they it's not that they just simply are
not fans of Andrew Jackson but they're
hostile toward Andrew Jackson and you
know you know what they're hostile for
them you know what everybody knows about
Andrew Jackson every school kid knows
about Andrew Jackson Andrew Jackson's
Indian policy Andrew Jackson and the
Trail of Tears though that's those are
the two that are put together and
there's no question that Andrew
Jackson's policy toward Indians does not
go down well today because it's not our
policy toward Indians it's not the way
most of us think that Indians ought to
be or ought to have been treated now as
the historian what I have to do is
explain why Jackson adopted the policy
that he did in particular the policy of
Indian Removal if one wanted to be harsh
today one would call it a policy of
ethnic cleansing Jackson took the
position that the Indians could not must
not remain east of the Mississippi River
well wait a minute that's not exactly
what he said that's what everybody knows
but it's not quite right in fact Jackson
said that Indians including the
Cherokees and this is the famous case of
Jackson in the Supreme Court and the
Cherokees and ultimately the Trail of
Tears
Jackson's policy was that the ending the
Cherokees could remain in Georgia if
they wanted to but if they did they
would have to abide by the laws of
Georgia just like everybody else living
in Georgia what Jackson could not accept
was the idea that the Cherokees would
live as a separate nation within Georgia
this offended his views of states rights
in fact Jackson was a strong states
rights man up to the point where states
rights threat
the Union Jackson was a remarkable
combination of a person who believed
that most law should emanate from the
states but the states could not threaten
the existence of the Union which is why
although he sympathized with South
Carolina regarding that tariff he said
once you start talking about secession
then then you no longer have my sympathy
anyway so Jackson believed that the
Cherokees could live as citizens of the
United States and citizens of Georgia in
Georgia but they couldn't live as a
people apart one of the things that's
not commonly known and it Jackson is
often portrayed as anti-indian Jackson
had two Indian foster children he these
were survivors of some of the the
battles that Jackson was involved in but
he took them and he raised them as his
own children and he looked after them as
well as he looked after his own he had
known he and Rachel had no natural-born
children his adopted children and so he
had nothing against Indians per se but
Indians here was his basic problem with
Indian living as separate nations they
had been in all of his life a threat to
the security of the United States
because Indians and Jackson's experience
had allied with the British had allied
with the French had allied with the
Spanish Indian nations were a threat to
America's existence now this is another
essential part of the Jackson story it's
something that we our generation has
entirely forgotten and this is something
that I have to make clear in the book
and that is when I say Jackson was a man
of his times Jackson had this
preoccupation almost an obsession with
the security of the United States in
Jackson's view the United States was
under siege and it was constantly on the
verge of falling apart well now we know
that it didn't fall apart and it became
the greatest most powerful country in
the world so it's very easy for us to
assume that it was always so or at least
that insightful people would have seen
that it was becoming so but Jackson
didn't see that for the very good reason
that what I just said is false when I
said it didn't fall apart yes it did
fall apart
remember there was this thing called the
Civil War and Jackson spent his whole
life trying to prevent a civil war
trying to prevent the United States from
coming under attack from foreign
countries so in Jackson's view the
United States was endangered endangered
from outside well of course it was
Jackson fought two wars against the
British the Revolutionary War in the war
of 1812 he bought a series of skirmishes
against the Spanish he had to deal with
the machinations of the French and
anybody else who might be threatening
the United States because the United
States during Jackson's age was a small
country in a big sea of much greater
powers and this was something he had to
deal with he also had to deal with the
internal threat and the internal threat
was very real from South Carolina during
his presidency but also as we know for
all Jackson's efforts to hold the Union
together it didn't stay together it fell
apart in 1861 and it was only held
together by the war that Jackson tried
to avert now there's a lot more that I
could say about Jackson I haven't even
touched on one of the best parts of the
story and that is Jackson's relationship
with Rachel this is one of the great
love stories of American public affairs
of American political history and it's a
particularly great story it's not simply
it's not simply a warm loving
relationship there were clouds over this
relationship at the beginning at the end
it was it was filled with passion it was
filled with death there was even what
some people called murder from the state
I don't recommend this for marriages but
from the standpoint of
the author trying to tell a story it's
great for the story I'm gonna stop and
give you a chance to ask some questions
I just have to tell you there's a lot
more in the book and if you want to get
it all then you should buy the book I
one of the things that my publisher
encourages me to remind you especially
anybody going to a fall Book Festival is
the holiday season is not far away and
biographies make great gifts so think
about yourself but think about those six
or a dozen people in your lives that
could use a book like this okay do you
have any questions yes sir any yes I'll
remind you please go to the microphone
if you do have questions yes sir
do you think it would be desirable in in
your your chronology of things to put
another biography between Jackson and
Roosevelt number one and number two can
you give us a hint who might come next
after Roosevelt well yeah actually I
think there should be somebody but there
definitely has to be somebody between
Jackson and Roosevelt because I've got
the problem that there's 12 years
between the death of jacks and the birth
of Roosevelt but the other thing is yeah
Jackson is well I won't say he's off the
political stage because right up until
the last moment of his life he's at the
center of things and for the Tennesseans
in the audience you'll like the ending
because I won't tell you exactly how it
ends but it involves Sam Houston and
Andrew Jackson and the culminating
moment of their two political careers
and how Houston hears that Jackson is
dying but the US Congress has finally
agreed to allow Texas into the Union so
Houston wants to be the one to take the
news to Jackson and so Houston races
toward the Hermitage and I won't tell
you how the race ends but
yes I do need to have somebody else and
I do have a particular individual in
mind I don't think it's gonna be the
next book that I'm gonna write maybe not
the next biography but I think there
needs to be a good study of William
Sherman and the reason I would pick
Sherman is that not that Sherman is
anybody's favorite general if Andrew
Jackson at times was kind of prickly
William Sherman was even more so but
here's the thing
oh and one of the points I make in the
the Jackson book is that Jackson was the
Herald of democracy I didn't even touch
on that what I said you know the great
thing about Jackson is Isaac as I said
it implicitly with the presidency be in
common man ACEF Jackson was the hero of
the age of democracy now we tend to
think of democracy as this unalloyed
good thing so if we can establish
democracy in Iraq or in the Middle East
then all will be well well democracy
worked has worked out okay for the
United States but I would remind you
that it had a very difficult youth and
adolescence and in fact if you look at
Jackson's own presidency the birthing
pains of democracy were severe and part
I would contend that the American Civil
War was a consequence of democracy but
that's the argument that i'ma make in
this book on William Sherman but the
other thing the point of the book on
Sherman will be in fact I even got a
working title for the book and it is the
dark heart of war because again this
isn't something that America we
Americans pride ourselves on but in a
very important way this is a country
that was built by war if you think about
it for a minute the way things that turn
out is not a triumph for democracy
exactly it's a try it was a triumph of
military force this country was settled
this this particular land was settled by
force Jackson spent the first 30 years
that he lived in Tennessee fighting
Indians
the Civil War you know what what
resolved the question of slavery what
resolved this question of the nation
versus the state it wasn't a Supreme
Court decision it wasn't a vote of the
people it was the fact that the north
crushed the south when those two issues
were put to a test now that doesn't
sound to me like a recommendation for
democracy and and I don't mean this as
you know our particular criticism
democracy I mean that's I think
democracy has turned out well for this
country but democracy is not by itself
the answer to all of humanity's problems
and a book on Sherman will take on that
issue other questions yes sir Oh
mr. branch I've got to say your
biography on Franklin is probably the
most interesting book I've ever read
very good I have to tell you I like it
but it's not as good as my Jackson boy
I'm looking forward to but you seem to
have a great ability to ferret out
fascinating tangents within the story
and a two-part question
what do you think you do differently
than other offer authors to enable you
to do that and weave it into the story
and also what was the most interesting
tangent and the end of Jackson book I'll
answer the second question first the
interesting tangent in the Jackson book
isn't exactly a tangent in fact as the
author who conceives of these books as
seamless works of art I would
respectfully reject the label tangent I
like to think if they're all central to
the story but I take your point and
Jackson's battle with Nicholas Biddle
over the bank of the United States
because it allows me to address a
remarkable question in American politics
that has absolutely disappeared from
political discourse you know what the
most confident the most consistently
controversial issue in American politics
from 1776 until the beginning of the
20th century was it wasn't slavery it
wasn't states rights those were big
right up until the 1860s but after that
forget it it was the money question what
constitutes money in
the United States who controls the money
supply how much money shall there be
those of you who remember your American
history remember they the presidential
campaign of 1896 where free silver is
what the Democrats wanted but this came
up again and again and again and it was
at the heart of Jackson's struggle with
Nicholas Biddle and the Bank of the
United States because the question was
who controls American money the
democratic system the people or the rich
folks who control the bank so there's
that that's I think a very interesting
point and it actually caused me to I'm
gonna write a little book on this
question and the first part of your
question was I forgot
Oh what do I do differently than other
ones well I said earlier on that
biographers tend to come their subjects
from either journalism or from history
and because I come from history I really
am
more interested in seeing how my
individual is representative of his or
her by the way I'm still looking for a
good woman subject to put in for one of
these volumes so if you have any
suggestions let me know it has to be
somebody big who can carry a big story
but I'm certainly willing to listen so I
pay a lot more attention to that kind of
things then say David McCullough Dave
McCulloch really concentrates on John
Adams and the what's going on outside of
Adams realm is kind of scenery but it's
definitely off stage for me a lot of the
those themes are as important as the
story of the life we have Christopher at
time for one more question okay one more
question yes sir yes sir there was a
book a few years ago on Andrew Jackson
I'm not sure if considered a full bark
for the aren't Andrew Bernstein yes yes
I gather that his interpretation of
Jackson differs from yours well I would
hesitate to say that I have an
interpretation of Jackson it is true
that editors a lot of readers and
definitely reviewers they want to know
am I for Jackson or against Jackson well
frankly I'm neither I'm no more for
Jackson or against Jackson than I'm for
I don't know Mount Rushmore or something
like that because Jackson was
this huge figure in American politics
and it's immaterial frankly to me as a
historian or to me is the author of
books a book that I want my readers to
read whether I like him or not and I
will say that there are things about
Andrew Jackson that I admire
tremendously his devotion to the Union
if not for Andrew Jackson you need have
fallen apart in the 1830s I happen to
think the Union is a good thing now you
know we could debate that and there are
some advocates of the Lost Cause who are
not so sure that the Union is a good
thing but there are certain aspect of
Jackson's life and career that I don't
admire but I don't sum it up I don't say
there's nowhere in the book that I say
Jackson was a good man I don't even say
in the book that Jackson was a great man
even though I think that's true great in
the sense of having a great effect on
his light on his times because if you
say great that often comes across as you
know I'm really for him but my job is to
make Jackson understandable to make this
person who was the most important figure
of the first half of the 19th century
did you ever think about the fact that
when people talk about different eras in
American history there's only one that's
named for an individual and that's the
Jacksonian era he was that big so what I
need to do is to make the Jacksonian era
understandable to our own era which
differs so much in all sorts of things
thank you very much I'm going to be
signing books somewhere out there and I
hope to see you all
HW brands is a professor of history at
the University of Texas at Austin his
books include
Lone Star nation and the age of gold
his latest Andrew Jackson is published
by doubleday an imprint of Random House
visit Random House dot-com / Doubleday
for more information